can film festival is celebration of
Cinema and galama a place for Pure
spectacle but also a space for quieter
slower paced films to shine
the ceremony started by honoring
American actor Michael Douglas for his
57-year career at merci beaucoup the
festival opens with the opulent
jandabahi a French historical drama
about Louis xv's favorite mistress
female director maiwen also plays the
lead with Johnny Depp as the French King
in his first role since his trials
involving Amber Heard
a diverse jury of actors writers and
directors will watch 21 films competing
for the Palm door prize can you just
tell me what qualities you're going to
Value most highly when it comes to
evaluating the films I love going into
films not knowing anything not having a
story behind it or expectation of any
kind and sometimes I'm just incredibly
surprised by things that move me and
sometimes it's about the right place at
the right time winner of two Palm doors
Reuben osland is head of this year's
jury known for his satirical films which
challenge issues of class power and
authority
just tell me what audiences can expect
from Cairn this year and what are you
looking forward to as head of the jury
that is an event that is fantastic to
share with the audience and this year
there's a lot of old dragons like Old
Masters of Cinema that is presenting the
film there are also some some younger
new directors and I'm really going to
look forward to look at films that you
know that the origin of the ID is
created during the pandemic why is
Cinema still important we are sitting in
front of individual screens and I think
that it's important that we reflect on
the content that we reflect on the
images that we are consuming because
they are changing how we look on the
world and they are changing our Behavior
so the cinema is a room where we
actually can reflect and that we can
have a discussion of the content that
we're watching over the next 12 days
these audiences will reflect on some 69
films first time films from Senegal
Sudan and Mongolia are going to be up
against established directors like Vin
vendors Ken Loach and Nanny Moretti and
while winning the Palm Door doesn't
always guarantee Commercial Success it
can launch a career change in audiences
perspective and does guarantee the
director's place in film history Charlie
Angela Al Jazeera can